escuchábamos al presidente duque decir
que este ataque era una retaliación por
parte de los grupos terroristas cuál es
la situación de esta región en la que se
registró este atentado
buenas tardes gracias por la invitación
la situación en cúcuta en norte de
santander se ha venido deteriorando la
situación de seguridad desde mitad de
año recordemos que en el mes de junio
julio hubo un atentado contra el
presidente de la republica en este mismo
inmediaciones de este mismo aeropuerto
cuando intentaba aterrizar en el
helicóptero presidencial también hubo un
atentado contra la brigada 30 que es la
guarnición más importante de esta ciudad
que es la ciudad fronteriza en la
frontera colombo-venezolana entonces la
situación se ha venido deteriorando en
los pasados meses debido pues a la
conflictividad armada la región del
catatumbo donde hay al menos 5 grupos
armados y también por el deterioro de la
seguridad en la frontera
colombo-venezolana asociada al cierre de
la frontera desde el año 2015
'jorge preocupa ver este tipo de ataques
a poco más de cinco meses de la primera
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
en colombia
por supuesto las elecciones
presidenciales en colombia el próximo
año son muy importantes no solo por el
contexto de gran polarización política
que ha afectado al país también desde el
paro nacional en mayo pasado que dejó un
saldo de personas muertas y heridas
importantes sino también porque en
diferentes regiones del país la
seguridad se ha venido deteriorando no
solo con este tipo de ataque sino
también con el incremento del número de
masacres de líderes sociales asesinados
ex combatientes asesinados
desplazamiento forzado todo es colombia
está enfrentando un panorama complejo
desde el punto de vista de seguridad que
tiene unas implicaciones territoriales
muy importantes